uh i have a story for you today
that is a story about many things we've
been talking about and fundamentally the
story is about conspiracy theorists
moving to
central and south america mexico and
central america and um starting kind of
conspiracy off the grid communes and
it's really wild but
it points to a number of different
issues we've talked about one is these
people rarely believe only one
conspiracy and that's what can make them
so so dangerous number two
there's almost always anti-semitism
there if you find any real conspiracy
believer there will almost always be
some openly or implicitly anti-semitic
belief and of course they're completely
unhinged so let's look at this clip this
is from vice news vice news went down to
check out these enclaves and uh
it speaks for itself
the brothers bring potential buyers to
tour the community of about 214 lots
right each lot starts at twenty thousand
dollars plus the cost of building a
house
about twenty percent of them have sold
people have asked me gabo so
i like ac can i have ac i said yes
you can have all the comforts you want
you can have internet you can have cable
tv
uh you're gonna have a nice kitchen so
it's like living in the city but in the
jungle right okay so we're gonna walk to
the phase two okay so where the lots are
available
okay
all of the conveniences of modern
society without any of its laws sounds
like a utopia
but when all conspiracies are given
equal credence some dark ideas can
appear this is wild what brings you here
today joanne we have a
big bunch of demons that are um
trying to control our lives uh so let's
see what's going on because we might
have to head to the hills so now here
with demons she might mean literal or
metaphorical demons we don't yet know
but just wait
i am worried about the graphene oxide in
the injections and i'm worried about the
um the vaccines covered vaccines well
they're not vaccines so i will not call
them that their injections their
injections of graphene oxide when you
add graphene oxide into the body and
you're hooking that to the cloud
this is craziness it's just hard for me
because so much of what you're saying
like i've never heard of before and it
goes against like a lot of the things
that i've been told are true you have
been i would even say it more strongly
because when you say you haven't heard
of something it's easy to say well you
got to inform yourself
what really it's i there's been no
evidence presented
to suggest any of this is true
for so much and then you can kind of get
into something else which i accidentally
stumbled upon which was
were there gas chambers in nazi germany
and there is six million people die in
that's in germany yes well
that's a great answer but it's probably
the wrong answer but people watching
have lost relatives in the holocaust
they know people died so what you are
saying feels like an attack on them
personally no you're putting words in my
mouth and words in their mouth what does
this have to do with
like off-grid living life so maybe
people can't see the lie in what's going
on with covet 19 but there are many
books and many many experts
took apart the gas chamber story 101
different ways
what do the rest of you guys think of
this there's always going to be
difference of opinions between people
this is normal human trait so we should
not um judge people based on what they
say or they don't say joanne is welcome
here everybody's well absolutely
all of these alternative communities are
brought together by one thing
they're against the covet 19 vaccines
and mandates yeah so it's it's very very
scary stuff and this is why i tend to
agree increasingly with the conspiracy
and cult experts we talk to who say yeah
you know maybe they believe flat earth
stuff or they just don't want the
vaccine personally because they think
there's graphene oxide in it and it'll
link you up to the cloud or whatever but
there's often really ugly stuff
underlying it exactly as you saw there
and unfortunately that is not going to
be someone you can talk sense into